this video was sponsored by bessie
[Music]
what is the oldest human occupation okay
fine it's prostitution but what is the
second oldest human occupation
you guessed that spies gathering intel
espionage
[Music]
why well all spying really is is getting
information getting knowledge about our
enemies before we make a move
this type of knowledge is also known as
foreknowledge
and because information about our
enemies about the world around us is so
vital to our basic survival spying
quickly emerged as humanity's oldest
occupation
second only to our more intimate urges
as sun tzu said if you think about it
the only way to get ahead in life to
crush your enemies
whether that be other nations or
dictator you want to take down or oil
fields you want to control or the
current global superpower that you want
to destroy so you can take the throne
to submit your name in the history books
if you want to do any of this
you're gonna need for knowledge
intelligence and the only way to get
that intel on what your enemies are up
to
you're not gonna get it by praying to
the gods but from other
men so the million dollar question
becomes how do you go about getting said
intel from other men
well then let's learn the art of
[Music]
spycraft
spycraft is one of the most
misunderstood and misrepresented
professions in the world
and for good reason the more the public
knows about how their country's
espionage works
the more your enemies know too you can't
tell when clandestine operations go well
but you sure can when they don't leading
the public not to value spying all that
much
and at the end of the day espionage is
all about collecting that juicy intel on
our enemies
[Music]
there are two ways you can go about this
the first way is to collect intel
overtly this is through reading
newspapers to press all the public
information that comes out of an enemy's
country
whether it be from journalists or your
average citizen the problem with this
public information is just that
it's public you're not gonna find many
secrets in there but if you do it's
gonna take a lot of manpower to find
that needle in the haystack
the other problem is that overt intel
collection only works if the country has
this pesky thing called freedom of press
if it's a place like china where
disobedient journalists magically
disappear from time to time
good luck finding anything of value and
better luck not falling for any fake
intel their government planted in there
that is why clandestine intel collection
or espionage the official name for it
always has a place in this world
the essence of espionage is access
here's how it generally works
you choose the objective of what you
want to know about your enemy the target
is usually something large and easily
recognizable like missile testing
grounds or nuclear plant
but it can also be smaller things like
conversations files or what have you
since the intel you want to know is
probably important to your enemy
they're gonna place very difficult
obstacles in your way to your target
the more control the enemy has over its
own people the more obstacles they're
able to set up
this can be the geographical location
security very strict protocols etc
now that you have the target id'd you
need to get an agent or some kind of
device close enough to the target to get
access to that target
to gather the intel you need while not
arousing any attention from those who
protect the target
once you collect that intel your agent
then has to deliver the intel to you
without
getting lost or intercepted in routes
intel is useless if it takes too long to
get back to you so speed is of the
essence in this part of the journey
now that you understand how clandestine
operations work let's take a look at the
agents that carry out these risky
missions
[Music]
jesus christ that's jason
bourne there are five different types of
spies native spies getting locals that
live within your enemies borders to spy
for you
internal spies getting insider officials
to relay intel to you
double agent spies when you get a hold
of an enemy spy and get them to turn on
their country
for you there are also expendable spies
basically ponds where you have them feed
the enemy false information to throw
them off
knowing that the enemy will probably
kill that spy once they find out that
intel is fake
and lastly there are living spies our
spies that do the clandestine operations
that we just talked about they go off to
infiltrate the enemy get access to the
objective and come back alive to tell
the tale
these are usually the type of spies
people are referring to when they think
about the typical secret undercover
agent
because a spy's job is so dangerous they
require a certain set of skills
you are able to judge people well to
tell whether or not a person is bsing
you not telling you the whole story if
they have ulterior motives
you need to be able to work well with
others under some very difficult
circumstances
you're able to pick up very small
details like body language clothing etc
you're able to adapt and blend into
different cultures and of course you're
able to keep your mouth shut when you
need to
once you get past those basic traits
intelligence agencies will typically
need people with a very specific
background or set of skills for each
clandestine
operation maybe they need a middle-aged
man married knows english and french and
has a background
in engineering or coding for example
they'll enter these requirements into
their database
comb through all the potential agents
for this mission and hopefully we'll
find the right person for the job but
this is typically where you run into
some roadblocks
first off if they're able to gain access
to a target they probably won't be able
to stay there for very long
secondly if an agent is skilled enough
to break into a nuclear weapons facility
in china or the soviet union back in the
days
they probably wouldn't have the
knowledge to report back anything
meaningful about these complex targets
after all if you don't know much about
nukes you're probably not going to
discover anything new about them no
matter how close you get to one
so these types of spies have their
limits this is where plants come in
no not those kind of plants
planted agents are agents that are
somehow able to penetrate the target
and stay there for an extended period of
time usually by acting as an official or
employee layer
the biggest advantage of planted agents
is that since they appear on the outside
to be on the same team as the enemy the
enemy usually just assumes that your
agent is one of the good guys and don't
look further into them
the only way to have planted agents
today is either by using illegals or by
turning someone who's already on the
inside
illegals not illegal immigrants are deep
cover agents that are rebuilt from the
ground up with new fictional backgrounds
through years and years of training
very large part of the training was
operational work determination as to
whether you're being under surveillance
morse code a shortwave radio reception
their agency makes them fake documents
passports and their fake identity has to
be backstopped
if your fictitious identity is from
germany you have to be able to talk
act and have the same mannerisms as
someone who grew up there the agency has
a set of contingencies to make sure that
if you were investigated by the enemy
there are people or documents in germany
that confirms your origin
agencies will even sometimes look at
gravestones and cemeteries to find a
dead person that matches your age to use
and one day a diplomat out of the soviet
embassy in washington
came across this tombstone just outside
of dc
and they said guess what we have a birth
certificate we're going to the u.s
and that was the jack barski birth
certificate that
somebody had obtained and i was given i
didn't have to get this myself
now obviously grooming illegals takes a
lot of resources and time
and if you can't insert an illegal into
your target your other option is to find
someone who's already inside
this can be someone who's already in the
perfect spot to gather intel for you
or it can be someone who's just starting
their career or in the middle of their
career climbing up the ranks and will
eventually graduate into the spot you're
after
the benefit of these types of spies are
that they're already perfectly qualified
to interpret the information
they're already trusted by the enemy and
won't take years of training like an
illegal
these type of people are what we call in
place why would an insider turn on their
own country there are many motivations
maybe a young russian adventurer was
lured by the money and materialism of
the west
maybe today a chinese official is
starting to feel disillusioned with what
their regime is up to
maybe the trader can see that their ship
is sinking right before their eyes and
they want to jump onto a new ship before
it's too late
maybe you spy on them find some dirt and
blackmail them into becoming an agent
for you or else
your job is to simply learn a potential
trader's key pain points and make them
an offer they can't refuse
once you have whatever kind of agent or
plant you manage to get on the inside
they'll do their job and hopefully have
some intel to relay back to you
so now it's time to collect that intel
[Music]
collecting that intel is pretty simple
agents can place bugs hidden cameras
take pictures with their phone etc
getting that intel back to their
superiors is a different story
today with the internet and dark web
it's probably pretty easy to relate
information back to whatever agency
you're working for
for example back in the cold war days
spies had to get a little creative with
passing on their intel
as the classic brush passes where an
agent nonchalantly gets their handler
intel in a public place while walking
past each other or sitting down
there are dead drops where spots drop
off intel at specific locations
illegals would have radios that they
would use to transmit intel back to
moscow or wherever
one cool trick they did to avoid getting
tracked down as they were transmitting
would be to record the report beforehand
and play the recording back through the
radio at a faster speed the motherland
would then slow down the audio to
understand it
and as late as 2010 it was found that
russian sleeper agents in america used
more modern clever ways to relay
information back to russia
the illegals sat in coffee shops and
flashed messages from their laptops to
suspicious vehicles parked outside
coded texts were embedded in images
posted online
and of course there has been a long
history of spies using codes and ciphers
to encrypt messages before sending it
back and forth
now if you're gonna subvert your enemies
with spies you can bet that they're
probably gonna do the same to you
this is where counter intelligence comes
in protecting your nation and your power
against
outside espionage for
counterintelligence you basically do the
opposite of what you do to spy on other
nations
for our clandestine operations remember
we picked the target
figured out how to get past the
obstacles in the way chose someone to
get access to that target either an
agent or by turning someone who's
already in place
and this is how other powers are gonna
approach infiltrating your nation as
well so find out what foreign
intelligence agencies would likely want
to know about your plans
figure out how they're gonna go about
doing so what kind of people they're
gonna use and of course who those spies
are
catching spies is a little bit outside
the scope of this video so let's assume
you catch a foreign spy
what do you do next well we have a very
big opportunity here
see on one hand you can expose them and
put an end to your enemy's espionage
operation
but you don't really get anything else
beyond that on the other hand
if you can turn the spy into a double
agent you can fool your enemy into
thinking that they still have the upper
hand while also spoon feeding them false
information from their trusted agents
turning a double agent is surprisingly
pretty easy in the us espionage is
punishable by up to 20 years in prison
so many spies will gladly take a deal
over two decades in prison or the
possible death sentences of other
countries
once you have an enemy spy under your
control start by having them report back
real intel to the superiors
real intel that they can verify but is
also harmless so everything seems to be
going okay
your hope is that the mother country
will give them more assignments more
assignments means that you can get more
intel on what your enemy is after their
methods maybe even other spots on the
ground
and the more assignments the more
opportunities for you to subvert them
right back
so now that you know the importance of
spycraft getting intel about your
enemies from other men
how espionage is all about gaining
access to a target via
agents or plants how agents can relate
intel back to you and the importance of
counter intelligence
you now have almost all the tools you
need to spy your way to world domination
if you want to be a spy yourself you
could get into some
tricky situations
especially if you're spying in not so
friendly parts of the world
you might have to evade capture fight
participate in a real life chase scene
straight out of a james bond movie
the problem is this is gonna happen
while you're undercover and if you're
undercover
you're probably not gonna be wearing
combat boots you're gonna be in casual
attire that blends in
casual attire that usually doesn't lend
itself well to running or fighting
this is where vessi comes in the world's
first waterproof knit shoes
they offer very stylish shoes that blend
and yet are 100 waterproof
whoa that's crazy to see
man it just bounces right off this isn't
some waterproof coating that's gonna rub
off either it's integrated directly into
the fabric itself and let me tell you
it's pretty trippy to see in person
what's cool is that even though it's
waterproof they're still very much
breathable and lightweight as other
non-waterproof shoes of its kind
they sent me their everyday sneakers in
black because what other color would i
get and i've been wearing them for the
past few weeks and have been loving it
they're just as light as my adidas
sneakers but waterproof super comfy and
here's what happened when i tried to get
some b-roll for their sponsor spot at
the beach
needless to say the waterproofing still
held up but on top of that i was on an
outdoor event last month during a
hurricane in texas
it was pouring mud and water seeped
through the walls of my shoes and got my
socks all wet the entire
time and i would have killed for a pair
of shoes like these
really impressed definitely worth the
money they have a few different styles
you can pick from including their new
weekend design
and if you use the code jake at
bestiefootword.com
jake you'll get an additional 25 off
along with their standard free shipping
and free exchanges
so get yourself a pair and prepare your
fee for whatever life throws at it
whether that be puddles outdoor
adventures or the occasional spy chase
are you guys excited for no time to die
to finally come out in theaters i know i
sure am
screw you pandemic let me know if you
guys want more spy videos maybe we can
do like one on corporate espionage or
maybe one specifically on like illegals
just let me know in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video we make video
essays just like this one every single
week on the most provocative stuff in
the world of business so if you enjoyed
this one
you will probably enjoy the other one so
make sure you click that subscribe
button and the notification bell below
if you want like behind the scenes stuff
then the live kind of stuff
means me complaining about stuff you can
follow me on instagram jaketrend.io we
have a ton of fun over there
so yeah check trying to io do you guys
like this godfather vibe we have going
on out here we're trying out some new
stuff so let me know what you guys think
but that is going to wrap it up for this
video so thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome i've been jake
stay dangerous out there and i'll see
you guys in the next one
you shouldn't stand why you shouldn't
look like that
[Music]
you know i think you're wrong i am
we always have a choice
i'll do that